Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my Full Rick and Morty
Season 7 Episode 9 Video
There are a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references,
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
We only have one episode left
The finale is going to be next week.
as far as they've said
Season 8 will also premiere at the end of 2024,
around the same time that Season 7 premiered.
careful for spoilers from the episode.
If you haven't seen it yet, we'll start
at the beginning, work our way through shot
by shot, talking about Easter Eggs and WTF moments,
starting with the episode
titled Mort Ragnarick
which is a reference to Thor Ragnarok.
There were a bunch of Marvel references
like a bunch of Thor references in the episode
because they dealt a lot with Valhalla.
The Norse idea of the afterlife.
Rick and Morty also did a full commercial parody
of God of War Ragnarok,
which is based on a lot of similar mythology.
Is this episode?
God of war. Morty The new one. Kratos is a dad.
The kid is curious like you.
Morty, going to the ninth round.
my God.
Finally, the Leviathan
ax and other unannounced upgrades.
I I found a boat, Morty.
You're going to row, though.
Not me. It's.
It's a big ax.
And I have to make sure it doesn't get wet.
there are a couple of big movie parodies too,
like the whole live die repeat of it
all, the Tom Cruise movie, during the episode,
though, Rick is trying to harness
the energy of another dimension
to gain theoretically limitless power.
It's a little bit
like the concept behind zero point Energy.
If you've ever watched the Stargate TV series,
they kind of get into it during that with the Zero
point modules
basically pulling energy from another dimension.
during the episode,
though, Rick actually proves the existence of a heaven
like alternate dimension in alternate dimensions
based on other religions
inside the Rick and Morty multiverse
that previously canonize the devil.
so for a long time fans have just assumed
that there was a God in heaven did exist.
If the devil existed in hell existed
that's why Rick making such a huge deal
about proving Heaven's existence.
The episode seemed a little redundant,
but one of the things that they have not done before,
and they do in the opening scene is actually
literally visit that version of heaven that he proves
the existence of like nobody in an episode
had ever actually traveled to a version of heaven.
Yet They reveal Rick had been repeatedly killing Jerry
for brief periods to see what happens to him
after he dies.
that part of the plot is actually a parody of the movie
Flatliners, where a bunch of medical school students
try to discover if there is some sort of afterlife
by trying to kill each other briefly
in pursuit of the goal, we find out
Jerry keeps being greeted by his grandparents
at Saint Peter's gates like the pearly gates
to actual heaven only this time
because he's been doing it so many times.
His grandfather refuses to come outside
the gates to greet him like, you've been teasing us
too much with the idea.
Like either choose to come in
or never come back in the way
that Rick explains how this heaven exists
in the Rick and Morty multiverse.
It's very similar to the way that Marvel
explains their version of the afterlife.
Inside the MCU.
when you die in the Rick and Morty multiverse.
As Rick reveals,
your consciousness is drawn to an alternate dimension
made up of like minded people's consciousnesses, self
propagating the dimension itself.
Rick has a very technical way of explaining it,
but it's basically him saying that Jerry,
as a Christian and all the other Christians
that exist in this dimension,
will a version of heaven into existence
and keep it alive with their continued belief in it.
but in a larger sense, in Rick and Morty
and inside the Marvel Universe,
your consciousness is drawn to an alternate dimension
based on your belief system.
So if you don't believe in heaven, like you're
not a Christian, you don't believe in heaven,
you believe in some other kind of afterlife,
like the do what the Egyptian Afterlife
in the New Nite series, for example,
your consciousness travels there after you die.
when Rick says This heaven only exists
for neurotypicals like Jerry,
he means that it only exists for people
who share the same belief in it.
Like Christians, for example, Neuro
divergence, as Rick says he is, is basically exactly
what you think that it means.
people whose brains literally work in a different way
so they don't understand things the same way,
like they're really awkward in social situations.
Rick kind of references that later
when he says he's dumb about understanding
when people are smart, like Bigfoot, for example.
previously on the show
Rick has revealed that he does have
a version of Asperger's like he is somewhat autistic.
when he says he
doesn't want to get into anywhere,
that's kind of a Groucho Marx reference,
like not wanting to belong to any club
that would be willing to have him.
Also, he says he refuses to believe
in religion, heaven in general, the way that Jerry does
His joke about the 1980s
looking version of Heaven is just a reference
to the many, many low budget movies based on heaven
or having heaven in them during the 1980s.
Like all dogs go to Heaven made in Heaven,
The Heavenly Kid.
There are many movies
that deal with heaven from the 1980s, when he talks
about the paradox that he's in
and why he can't tap this heaven dimension for energy.
he understands too much.
He knows too much about the way existence
actually works in order to actually be able
to get in to this alternate heaven dimension
that Jerry just visited.
so that's part of the irony.
Like he knows that it exists,
but he knows too much about how it exists to be able
to actually get in there.
so his backup plan is to travel to another afterlife,
alternate dimension that doesn't have quite
as stringent rules as this version of heaven,
which in his case is Valhalla.
I already explained the Thor Ragnarok reference.
But in the Thor movies, in the Marvel Universe,
they actually literally traveled
to the MCU version of Valhalla
during the Thor Love and Thunder Post-Credits scene.
we'll probably see that again at some point.
Or maybe reference it again during the events
of Avengers Secret Wars, or maybe Avengers five.
when the garage I voice says Phoenix Protocol is active.
That's a reference to Rick's Operation
Phoenix earlier on the show wherein he had many backup
clones and continues to have them down in his lab
beneath the garage Any time he gets killed,
part of
his failsafe plan that he has active in all dimensions
is that any time he's killed, no matter what
dimension he's in, his consciousness will just travel
to the nearest body, regardless of dimension.
So like it will travel across dimensions.
They use it as a huge bit during season four in fact,
the title of that episode
was also a reference to the movie Live Die.
Repeat Morty reveals that he has killed Rick
so many times in pursuit of this goal
and just other random times in their adventures
throughout their regular adventures
that have nothing to do with this.
and because of that, he's become so desensitized
to the idea of killing someone
that he got him in trouble at school
with Homeland Security
Leading Rick to all of his Pokémon
Pokeball jokes that they use across the episode.
Rick reveals that he's been keeping Bigfoot
inside a Pokeball recently
because they referenced Bigfoot living in another state
in a previous episode this season.
So he couldn't have had Bigfoot in that pokeball
for that long.
but essentially he's been torturing it inside there,
just getting it super pissed off
so that it will kill him
and he can get it to battle him, kill him,
and then devour Halla, basically
fulfilling the requirements to make it into Valhalla.
Per the Norse idea of the afterlife,
I guess part of the requirement for
that is also that it happens inside a Norse country.
So like they couldn't do this in the garage
in a lot of you probably remembered
that being killed by Bigfoot
actually fulfills the prophecy that was given to him
in the previous episode
this season, saying that he would be killed by Bigfoot.
you know, I'm assuming they change the pokeball to
green to avoid getting sued by Nintendo like Nintendo.
Please don't sue us. Send us free stuff.
Every time I think of Nintendo references in episodes,
I think of the Nintendo rant from back in season two.
the funny thing about that, though,
there are so many Nintendo references
during this episode, even playing Nintendo sounds,
but some of the animations that they do
are also based on Pocket Mortis,
which itself is a Rick and Morty game
in real life that you can actually download
that is based on Pokémon.
like literally after every single Rick and Morty
episode, they always have like the pocket Morty's
that they add to the game after the episode
based on characters from that episode.
the funny thing
though, is that in all these years of me making Rick
and Morty videos,
I don't think I've actually played Pocket Morty.
Maybe I play it like once a long, long time ago,
but rarely,
if ever, Rick Making references to the Bigfoot Bee
story in there.
A story of heaven is kind of ironic in
that it's a reference to Dan Harmon
clowning on storytelling tropes
and previously he's talked about how much he doesn't
like the idea that you're always forced
to connect A and B stories by the ends of episodes,
like why does it have to be that way
but during this episode, the ironic part
is that the B story winds up
connecting to the AIDS story
when Bigfoot becomes part of Rick's team
trying to kill and capture the Pope.
after he gets killed,
the first time he wakes up in Valhalla,
then, per the rules of Valhalla gets killed in battle,
resurrects inside their holes
for the thieves destined to repeat that process
till he escapes back to the physical universe.
notice inside the halls of Valhalla.
Two of those are Norse runes in the background.
The two crows are Odin's crows.
They also use that trope during season
five Rick and two crows
when he goes to the Forge master to steal those tools.
His hammer is a reference to Mjolnir.
Thor's hammer
Bigfoot tricks Morty into opening the cage,
proving its intelligence, then killing Morty,
sending him to Valhalla, too.
Because Morty died while fighting it,
Then Morty makes a Dragon Ball reference.
Then when Rick pretends to be Odin, he makes a bunch
more Marvel references like Thor's father.
Spider-Man's uncle.
that's actually a reference
to an alternate universe version of Odin
that wound up marrying Aunt May, becoming
Peter's uncle.
Undercover Boss is an actual TV show in real life.
And Odin in the MCU
is actually currently inside their version of Valhalla
after having died during the events of Thor Ragnarok,
which is the title of this episode.
Basically Bigfoot winds up using Rick's Metal Inspector
Gadget
body parts to break open his too,
causing his clone to run amuck.
The whole idea is that Rick's clones
all have this low level of intelligence,
like a fight or flight instinct.
That's why it can run for its life from Bigfoot.
But it doesn't really have any actual intelligence,
so it just sounds like complete nonsense.
Bigfoot then gets captured by the Vatican
and the whole bit with the pope forcing it to become
its killer is kind of a parody of The Da Vinci Code
with the silent character played by Paul Bettany.
Like, he kind of becomes that Paul Bettany character.
the montage of Morti continually killing the Vikings
over and over and then coming back in greater
numbers and rate making bigger and bigger weapons
each time is a parody of Live Die.
Repeat the Tom Cruise movie.
They also use that later in the episode
when they're fighting the pope over and over again.
Then Rick reveals the real reason why he wants to tap
the infinite energy of this alternate dimension.
It's because he won't need to rely on crystals anymore,
which run out of powder.
He has to refuel the crystals periodically
When they go back to the Vikings,
Rick calls Morty Spider-Man again
and basically gives him a version
of his Ten Commandments,
a parody of the Biblical Ten Commandments.
but as he says number one
commandment is to not go near the energy relay.
there's a big montage of the pope using Bigfoot
to kill a bunch of different people and businesses
that he doesn't like it.
He gives a bunch of devil worshipers, Then he sends
them after a parody version of Playboy magazine.
Secular means anything. Having no religious basis.
I guess the joke here is the Pope is fine
with nudie magazines that are religious themed.
he sends them to destroy
a nondenominational candle factory, I guess so
the pope can corner the candle market for some reason.
they have another predator joke
referencing all the muskets
you see in Predator movies
and a callback to the Predator musket.
Earlier this season in the Hugh Jackman episode
with the pope's aide claiming that the muskets are just
the predator's natural currency, like, so that's why
they all have muskets on them all the time.
basically trading the predator's armband
that he can use for communication for three muskets.
Rick and Morty make it back to their main dimension.
Just as the pope hacks into his energy
relay, giving him the infinite energy
that he uses to continually kill them later,
when Bigfoot does the movie guy
voiceover parody the reference in a world where time
actually is money is a reference to the movie in time
where currency is actual time,
their whole fight across the end of the episode against
the Pope is a parody of the end
of the live die repeat movie
where they try to kill the final boss.
each time they come back with different weapons.
Armor allies sometimes are funnier than others.
I sometimes get a little bit silly
The first time Rick makes a Criss
Angel joke who levitates in one of his magic tricks.
they get sent back to Valhalla.
Then eventually, after they get sent back a couple of
times, Morty makes a joke about speeding things up.
Like, maybe we can skip over some of these parts
and just teleport closer to him.
When we come back, They come back and put Bigfoot's
consciousness into Somer's body, which Rick is stored
because apparently she's like the next
most likely person in the family after Morty to die,
probably because she goes on
so many adventures with Rick, more
so than Beth and Jerry They notice Rick's portal
gun shell.
They mostly use it in this episode
to sort of keep track of how many times
they've been through this cycle of living dying
in repeating You can let me know in the comments,
though, before this episode, why did Rick have
so many different variants of his Portal Gun?
maybe,
he just keeps extras from other adventures around
Next time they put Bigfoot in a bigger, stronger body,
they make a muppets.
Joe too, like our bunch of burns.
In the episode They skip a couple rounds like notice
how each time they come back,
there are way more portal guns missing.
Like they just skip over a couple rounds.
These are meant to be the power suits
based on the Ronin warriors from season four.
Morty has a power suit from Luke, who's purging in
the green power suit is from the Thanksgiving episode
One time they try using pillow armor for some reason,
maybe just to try it out
Then they get help from the other classic
supernatural monsters that the Pope has locked up.
And these are based on the universal monsters.
Dracula, the werewolf creature from the Black Lagoon,
the Mummy Frankenstein.
there.
A couple of jokes
about the logic of how their bodies work
when they all get killed and sent to the afterlife.
Like the mummy gets his full human body regenerated.
Notice Dracula is human again.
Like he's not a vampire anymore.
The werewolf doesn't have a curse on him.
But the creature from the Black
Lagoon is still a creature
because he wasn't cursed like he was born that way.
But Rick calls out the Frankenstein bit
because he regenerated as parts.
Like, how did the parts make it into Valhalla?
Why didn't just regenerate
the original part of his body that he was based on?
the reason why the mummy knows what beer is
and what it smells like is a reference to in real life.
They actually made a version of beer in ancient Egypt.
Like that's an actual real thing.
then Rick basically gives up on the idea of wanting
infinite energy and tricks the Vikings
into destroying the energy.
Really?
Because it will also mean the Pope loses access
to the infinite energy as well.
but it also winds up
stranding the supernatural creatures there
like he uses them as cannon fodder basically.
So there are no more of these supernatural creatures
in the main dimension that they're from.
no Dracula, no Frankenstein, werewolf
or creature from the Black Lagoon any more.
Just because they're stuck in Valhalla
he brings Bigfoot, though,
because he's developed a soft spot for him
in the episode and doesn't want to leave him behind.
But also he still needs his help to defeat the Pope.
when they come back the last time, I think the Harlem
Globetrotters joke is just a reference
to all the crossover movies and TV episodes that
the Harlem Globetrotters have done in their existence.
like they've even had crossover episodes
with Scooby Doo.
when he captures the pope in his pokeball,
the Pope takes the Lord's name in vain saying,
God damn They also use classic Pokémon
sounds and emotes for Pokéballs.
When you capture Pokémon
in Rick perceives on this big Pokeball Pokémon bit.
I think just to lay on that,
it is meant to be a parody.
I think mostly for the benefit of Nintendo's lawyers.
So that they understand
that this is meant to be a parody.
Like if we make it super ridiculous,
then they'll definitely understand that it's a parody.
nobody knows how to sue people like Nintendo.
Like, seriously,
you'll hear more about lawsuits from Nintendo
against people just randomly around the world
than any other company.
the they basically end the episode with an over-the-top
bit about setting Bigfoot free in the wild,
but not understanding
even though they were meant to understand the episode.
And intelligent was that Big Foot is smart
now and wants to get
like a normal human job and live in the city.
Like, why are you throwing stuff at me?
I'm smart now.
I'm not an animal.
end, in the post-credits scene, they do a big Pokémon
Detective Pikachu reference with Rick
taking the Pope in his Pokémon ball to an underground
Pokémon fighting ring, just like the one in the movie.
Then running off
as soon as the police show up to bust them.
When they start the fight,
they also use a lot of Nintendo sound effects.
But the visual effect here
is actually from Pocket Mortis,
which, like I said, is
based on the Pokémon game itself.
in, I think the Pokémon that he was meant to fight here
is meant to be a parody of Charizard, then
revealing to the Pope once they rescue him that Rick's
imbecile clone has been named Pope in his absence.
Much to his horror.
you just think of that as Rick and Morty
saying that religion in general
is kind of silly in that way,
like clowning on all religion.
there were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references in the episode.
So if you spotted any that
I didn't talk about in the video, just write them below
in the comments and big reminder,
my Season seven Episode ten finale video
will air next week in the next big series
that I'll be doing episode videos for
after that will be Marvel's What if season 2
that will actually be in a couple of weeks.
I just did a really big trailer video for that
So I'll link it in the description below.
Everyone click here for that brand new Deadpool
3 Wolverine video
and click here for all my Rick and Morty Season
7 episodes
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!